welcome to this video playing Alonso
mostly from from Denmark he has no name
in the nope but a picture yeah does not
help me to identify the guy is not
looking like an under mostly from the
from the film okay let's play this again
and I really should get my rating to
something decent to 180 in five minute
is about as low as it gets should really
get in some some wins we are Queen Oates
f-sharp possibility trying for quick f5
whatever this these nights that can
easily be recorded now yeah let's say
let's call it the traffic jam on the on
the queenside with before being played
white of course has made so many pawn
moves that can it can backfire that's
that's clear but still it's a very huge
space advantage I think you can really
do that here before Effie 492 looks fine
or i can just take on e4 and taking on
g4s not scaring me
you can maybe play f4 and threaten age 6
hmm that's yeah this is probably why I'm
on to 180 at the moment he goes F for
threatening age 6 how do I actually how
do i save the bishop yeah or instantly
yeah here g5 Bishop d3 is at least
possible f4 i can go g5 as ugly as it
looks this is probably what i needed to
do on f4 bishop h4n don h6 play g5 yeah
that's maybe even possible i mean f 4g
five looks terribly ugly but it's um
it's probably a still I'm still probably
okay okay here yeah probably of course I
will never ever take the rook on f4 yeah
like Bishop g3 taking it I won't do that
opening up the long diagonal I just want
to play f3 Bishop e2 Bishop f2 and
consolidate yeah age 5 h 5s maybe a move
yeah I cannot go g5g five 9h 795 is very
weak okay I must do that probably not
move I love to play clearly but but
still TJ's got Bishop edge for but ok
this is not not necessarily dramatic i
can get the King to e2 and e3 Bishop to
h3 this is yeah this is this is
interesting and this I overlooked of
course oh come on what is this I the
moment terrible just terrible just
blundering one with us all the time I
just must play king e to first and then
I'm probably probably very ok yeah now I
have this Bishop on h1 just yeah now
playing this with being a couple of
moves down
ok let's see I'm probably a show caption
trait nevertheless now try to still get
the bishop some somehow to h3 and
exchange it maybe 2 e 3 mp3 to f5
yeah it maybe wants to place his 6 cm
maybe not sure what to do this is not
bad but still not sure this is right if
he takes it i always get you for and
have light square let's go flame 9 f6f
night g5g six so
and I can try maybe look g6 trying to to
do something down and see 5c 5 now can
be a can be annoying intending c6
loosening the cover of the f6 bishop
well I camera I'm okay again
okay well Knight f6 a half night g5 you
can play Knight f8 of course this is
possible there's some way to to make any
headway here I really i don't i don't
see
and I can play c5 but not sure what it
is doing c6 this night be six maybe now
c 6 ok time morning can take it in place
his six that's not not bad I can now
take it and play a b5 on Knight c3 is
also interesting then it's got d5 ok
sure to take it and now be 50 check ok
good defense may be here I am
check
hmm check
i'm good i'm on one second I didn't even
look at the clock jab to 2.45 really wow
yeah black was was already here to
totally neg on come on this is this a
certainty winning I just need to do it
right check takes be fire takes and
kinky three wins instead of King d5 via
kinky five wins as well because of King
e6 okay yeah I didn't I didn't look at
the clock was my main problem Qing Yi 6
is winning yeah I simply didn't look at
the clock and this this is a mistake it
seems of course very a very sharp
position FYI still winning I'm not sure
what he's doing him the ship f1 yeah and
TM here white is winning again yeah okay
I really absolutely didn't look at the
clock when I play to the plate of this
yeah it was a bit of a shame i mean
because after i had blundered to look h4
i graduate Liam outplayed him again yeah
if i go here yeah this this was here
that even group g1 check okay I'm not
seeing anything at the moment great yeah
what I was trying to say is even the
general structures it's very favorable
for white i get i get bishop h3n2
exchange my bad bishop i have two good
nights and it's just a very good
structure the night on a six is terribly
placed and yeah this group g1 was shown
and TI i needed to turn really am
I'll play him again which which in fact
happened and yeah I totally forgot about
the clock I was a hat on the club all
the time which somewhat made me not pay
attention here can defend with be five
but generals yeah here it was winning
with multiple Jack multiple ways isn't
this what is what about this isn't this
winning as well g5 and king is six yeah
there's always this idea combining this
and to the march of the f pawn something
like this this is too much this is
promoting sepan promotes poom yeah not a
good not a good shape at the moment
thanks for watching